economía aquí en directo américa me
acompaña en el estudio jorge hurtado
jorge buenas noches comenzamos hablando
de los activos refugio y cómo están
tomando fuerza en estos tiempos de
incertidumbre cuéntenos todos los
detalles por favor en santiago bueno es
que hay que tomar en cuenta el contexto
global con una inflación generalizada la
guerra en ucrania confinamientos en
china y agresivas políticas monetarias
los inversores buscan proteger su dinero
en ciertos activos considerados refugio
los favoritos históricos el dólar y el
oro estos últimos han jugado un papel
clave durante mucho tiempo sobre todo en
estos momentos de incertidumbre estos
activos también son llamados activos
defensivos por estar menos expuestos a
la volatilidad de los mercados
bursátiles para entender mejor qué es un
activo refugio conversamos antes con
andrés jiménez de la plataforma de
inversión freedom le preguntamos que
hace atractivo por ejemplo al dólar y el
oro
lo que sucede es que los inversionistas
que generan las instituciones durante
estos momentos de incertidumbre o de
mucha volatilidad en los mercados lo que
hacen es ir a los activos que
representen más seguridad y los otros
activos que menos volatilidad tengan en
los precios y en los cuales sepan que su
capital está más estable y por eso el
dólar es uno de los principales ya que
el 82 o más por ciento de la operación
en las transacciones del comercio
internacional es en dólares entonces es
una moneda muy fuerte y además de eso
que está respaldada por toda la economía
norteamericana y otro tipo de activos
que también se considera refugio por la
historia es el oro justamente por todas
las cualidades y capacidades que tiene
el oro como metal precio pero esto hace
que el capital cuando esté en ese tipo
de activos se encuentre mucho más
tranquilo que estando en activos digamos
de variable como las acciones porque
entonces le pregunto oro o dólar por
cuál votaría usted sin ser ninguna
recomendación de inversión mi favorito
es el oro porque el dólar todavía es muy
volátil a todo el contexto internacional
como lo hemos visto en los últimos días
pero entonces porque los activos refugio
en dollar han empezado a tomar mucha
fuerza a lo largo sobre todo este año
porque es una buena pregunta hay que
tomar en cuenta que la divisa
norteamericana tiene un lugar
privilegiado en el sistema monetario
mundial la mayoría de las reservas
extranjeras la mitad de todos los
préstamos y bonos internacionales así
como más del 40% del comercio
internacional se realiza en dólares esto
nos dijo al respecto nuestro invitado
perfecto cuando comparamos el dólar es
importante analizar reversos las monedas
referentes del mercado y para eso se
conoce un indicio como el white que es
el índice del dólar 300 la perfila seis
principales monedas y ahí podemos
analizar cómo ha sido su comportamiento
por el general no sólo versus cada una
de las monedas de latinoamérica sino
también veces el euro la libra y el yen
etcétera y analizando ese tipo de
instrumentos podemos ver cómo este año
ha crecido más del 14 por ciento y es
entender que el dólar se ha valorizado
mucho entendiéndose por la subida de las
tasas de interés y tener el capital se
ha hecho más costoso justamente porque
la subida de las tasas pues impide que
los lares se pueden adquirir de manera
más económica o barata en el mercado
pero además de eso es entender lo que ha
pasado con las otras monedas eléctricas
pero una zona euro completamente está
justamente por la invasión de anuncios
ucrania ve a gran bretaña alguna manera
también digamos que un poco ahí gold
enviada por esto el franco soy un poco
también golpeado por eso entonces no
solamente éste se ha valorizado
demasiado el dólar sino que también se
han desvalorizado las otras monedas y
esto ha llevado en claramente el dólar
coja mucha más fuerza a diferencia de un
activo refugio por tradición como el oro
que en promedio ha crecido entre un 5 y
un 8 por ciento
anual en los últimos 20 años jorge pero
tengo acá entre mis notas que en el caso
del oro ha perdido más de un 6% este año
porque a qué se debe ser esa ese
descenso bueno de hecho el activo se ha
visto afectado por las políticas de la
reserva federal de eeuu contra la
inflación y la subida de los tipos de
interés por ejemplo en este año el oro
llegó a apagarse por encima de los 2000
dólares la onza pero ahora ronda los
1.700 dólares por onza pese a esto el
metal precioso ha mostrado un positivo
crecimiento histórico sobreviviendo a
crisis económicas anteriores así lo
explica nuestro invitado
actualmente nos encontramos en
certidumbre con lo que está pasando en
los mercados internacionales los
inversionistas prefieren tener sus
activos sus ahorros guardados en
depósitos de activos refugio ya base de
euros por los dos tantos con el polo
como por héctor y es por eso que es
definido el último mes lanzamos un fondo
de ahorros en dólares y oro
históricamente el polvo ha crecido mucho
más que lo que ha crecido el dólar e
ibai uno compara el oro versus el dólar
y podemos ver que desde hace 20 años al
actual es de mucha mente el 2002 a la
fecha el oro ha crecido más del 430 por
ciento versus el dólar si comparamos el
bono versus el dólar en los últimos
cinco años ha crecido más de un 40 por
ciento muchas gracias jorge ahí les
dejamos el dato a conte en el debate
[Música]